[Music]
you're doing it again tonight
no please
that's my mom's Remembrance Day I just
want to forget about it huh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll do it
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
foreign
like the candle to open the door
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me
foreign
feel like
it felt amazing I can't see and feel
everything on the other side
I'll tell my mom she was trying to reach
out
here
still been seeing stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we opened the door but we didn't
shut it
oh my God they followed us
they're not gonna stop
you're never gonna stop
I like you
[Music]